[Music]
we do have a lot of interns that work
here at the show I think I treat them
pretty well they get amazing work
experience they get college credit so
recently we asked some of our departing
interns people who've worked for us for
a while another leaving to talk about
what they learned Wow they worked on the
show we put their answers together in a
little piece called my Konan internship
I was a graphics intern the first thing
they taught me was how to photoshop the
fear from Conan's eyes guys told me that
the holes in the wall of the women's
bathroom are for ventilation
Coenen brought me into his office and
said that sexual harassment laws don't
apply to people who aren't getting paid
Tommi every great comedy idea begins the
same way with 15 minutes of light
wrestling in his locked office I met
Conan a few times and he's just as funny
off the air as he is on the air which
was a little disappointing Conan O'Brien
is the kindest bravest warmest
I've ever known in my life and II
invited all the interns to lunch and
when the check came his phone rang he
took the call outside and we saw him run
to his car and he offered to write me a
letter of recommendation and here's what
he gave me
the worst part was how Conan and Andy
made a stand behind their chairs while
they ate
I learned that Conan is very comfortable
with his body and that the carpet
matches the drapes who did you feel was
the most attractive guy in the office oh
that's easy
Conan O'Brien column at the office you
can go to Bob at Human Resources but Bob
is just Conan doing this it was totally
worth it it was totally worth it bars
doing crap for free goes it wasn't that
crappy it wasn't too crappy it wasn't
too crappy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you